in our work in progress series with
LinkedIn we're looking at a growing
hiring trend job auditions an increasing
number of job candidates are actually
being asked to create a list of ideas or
complete an assignment before they are
offered the position LinkedIn says 32%
of hiring managers report using job
auditions to screen candidates and 84%
consider it an effective hiring tool but
it can elite excuse me actually alienate
thank you very much alienate some
prospective employees especially if they
do not get that job well Dan Roth is
from LinkedIn he's editor-in-chief there
dan good morning you know a lot of
hiring managers say that this is better
than a resume but the question I think
many people might have is is this fair
yeah I think that for it is a very
people were very split on whether this
is fair or not I think that for some
people this is a great way to show what
they know it is a great way to get into
a company especially if you don't have
the right background if you have gone to
the right schools the right schools and
suddenly you can just show off how you
think how you come up with plans but
you're also asking people employers
prospective employers we're asking
people to give up their time to give up
the most valuable resource which is how
they think yeah and to do it all for
free while they have another job or
while they're looking for a job they
could conceivably steal ideas
effectively from the viewers have some
of these auditions people report last
week's ya know they talk about this is a
creative theft so a lot of people feel
like they come in they give all their
ideas some companies are asking for
three five year plans saying they just
put these together spend the weekend put
these together and and for a prospect
who is let's say you're desperate for a
job you it's a hard calculus to make on
should I invest the time give up my
weekend stay away from my kids or take
time off from work and go do this I mean
very hard thing to figure out
so then what should a job seeker do if
they're confronted with this challenge
of like come in and do the job for a
little while there's a couple things
number one is you got to make sure there
is a job for a lot of job seekers
Knightmare Arlington saying I went and
interviewed for this position and it
became clear to me after the fifth sixth
seventh interview that they didn't know
what the position was it was unclear
whether there was a position and they
were just fishing for ideas so make sure
there is a job understand what the
details are and then
negotiate and also realized this is this
is dating you are yeah it's not just a
one-sided deal you got to figure out
whether you want to work for this
company so is there a benefit than if
those companies are able to pay you yeah
so a number of confidence I found this
we've I posted something about this 48
hours ago got three hundred and fifty
comments people saying that the craziest
stories but one of the most interesting
parts was that some companies are now
paying people for this and a lot of
people were surprised they said I came
in and I spent a day helping a company
think through something in the suddenly
they got a check so kind of like
freelance that seems like wait and I
think that's a win-win and it's
especially at a time where employer
branding is really important you don't
want to buy from a company that's
treated you poorly paying them helps
quickly then if a company asks you for
ideas in this audition yeah what do you
what do you say I mean I think that you
need to know internally what is the
what's your time limit I think that's
the most important thing so I'll be I'm
willing to give up to two hours of free
labor and I'll go and help the other
thing is think about giving general
ideas not tactics yes you want to
explain how you think not exactly what
you would do that's the key that's a
good tip all right yeah thank you very
much we appreciate
you